well hello they are watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages it is time then to see
what's making the headlines with sonia
soda chief leader writer of the observer
and christopher hope associate editor
for politics at the delhi telegraph
welcome to both of you great to see you
as ever though we turn our attention
straight away to the front pages
crunch time uk is the lead story in the
metro which reports that most people are
already cutting back on spending and
dipping into their savings as the cost
of living crisis bites
the telegraph says there's increased
pressure within the cabinet for the
chancellor to do something about it by
cutting taxes
the guardian leads with sexual
misconduct allegations against dj tim
westwood which have been made by a
number of women
the son has the latest on the
investigation into the man in custody on
suspicion of abducting madeleine mccann
in 2007.
the financial times reports on what
investors fear will be a fall in the
value of elon musk's tesla car company
if he sells part of it to pay for his
purchase of twitter
and the mirror has the heartwarming
story of a woman who's already given
away half of the 115 million pounds she
won on the lottery 10 years ago
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch the programme so let's bring in
sonia soda from the observer christopher
hope from the telegraph welcome to both
of you um crunch time it's all over the
papers is it not uh christopher you kick
us off then um the metro is uh quoting a
study by which it appears
which shows that most people have now
begun cutting back
that's right which are finding that 59
people are now cutting back on
essentials and this to me
is the beginning of the two or well a
little over a little over um 10-day run
in towards the local elections next
thursday
all of a sudden the politicians have
remembered what it's like to be out
there uh dealing with this uh with the
the twin all these pressures from
inflation from soaring energy bills um
or issues caused by the war in ukraine
and looking at how on earth are going to
help
people like you and me and others
watching this deal with this crisis one
idea has been looking at areas around
child care costs that's a kind of
important area but only a multiple area
given the scale of the challenge
facing the country and it was the key
topic and rightly so at today's cabinet
meeting you may argue this is now going
to push partygate to one side just the
next few days
well indeed you know why are they having
this brainstorming session in cabinet
now we've known this is coming for a
very very long time and all sorts of
ideas uh seem to be on the horizon let's
move to the financial times then sonia
shall we i'm suggesting there's been a
row over this idea of uh cutting food
tariffs and this after grocery bills
climbed by 5.9 percent in a year i mean
i know we're heading into summer it's
always been that you know do you heat
your home or
do you feed your children kind of line
but nonetheless food is something that
we all need to shop for isn't it
absolutely so this story is talking
about another idea that's emerged in the
cabinet the cabinet have been asked to
sort of think of innovative ideas to
help with the cost of living practice
and this is uh cutting food tariffs
unilaterally it's something that the
department for international trade are
opposed to because of course if you do
that it makes it much more difficult to
negotiate free trade deals with um you
know countries around the world and
indeed canada already there's already
been issues with canada saying well if
you're going to drop um tariffs
unilaterally for other countries why are
we going into a trade deal for that with
you um actually when we look at the high
costs of food some of that is accounted
for and in the article says this the
cost of brexit um extra checks at
borders etc so it's true that we've made
our lives more difficult for ourselves
when it comes to the cost of food but i
think when we take a step back from this
story in particular i think it shows how
desperate the government is how much
it's grasping at straws a couple of
other ideas on the table of sort of you
know switching mots for your car from
annually to every other year reducing
the ratios of
increasing the ratios rather the way
that the number of
children that nursery staff can can care
for to reduce nursery fees but these are
all quite marginal ideas for what is a
really really serious cost of living
crisis and the thing that the government
can't get away from is that some of this
crisis is due to factors outside of its
control for example really increasing
energy prices particularly um because of
the war in ukraine but a decade of
government policy has acted to make this
cost a living crisis worse so if you
look at tax credits and benefits that
support low paid parents for example
some parents have lost thousands of
pounds a year over over the last decade
from their household budgets you know
money to support their wages and to help
with the cost of child care and the
government has made some actions in the
last couple of years that have made that
worse so i think you know
there are real questions to be asked
about why the government's sort of
tinkering around the edges with mots
when it's actually directly through its
own decisions over the last decade slash
quite a lot from the budget of low-paid
parents for children
yes the telegraph runs through some more
of the ideas
including the mot's one you mentioned
which is that you get an mot every other
year not every year as you know as you
say it's not the greatest cost uh to
households uh reducing the cost of child
care you've already mentioned as well
christopher um and certain ministers
suggesting that tax uh reducing tax is
the best way to
to relieve the burden uh with sunak
saying what that we've run out of money
what's he what's he said effectively
well he's worrying about debt i mean the
big issue in the treasury is they're
worrying about the increased cost of
borrowing and and every every movement
in that price that cost is going to
hugely um be a big big problem for uk
state to deal with so he's winning the
argument at the moment and that's why
that insurance went up by two and a half
percent in april i was struck by that by
that um a line in the ft store i was
just reading that about showing that um
can kantar which is this uh
they're an index which looks the price
of food they're saying that food prices
have gone up for the average family by
271 pounds a year at the moment if you
add that onto the cost of um of energy
and a further increase in august due to
happening in october um i think
government is is really now finally
addressing
oh i would argue one of the one of the
key concerns for people out how on earth
you you tackle cosmic these are all
little ideas mot and the rest
but the key thing may have been not to
have gone ahead with that national
insurance increase which the telegraph
and other papers thought was a bad idea
but that ship was sale
yes and certainly um
a lot of the food costs are driven
because of
fuel aren't they energy bills whether
it's the distribution the making of the
cost of fertilizer something we had a
while ago all of it not helped by the
ukraine war and all of it not helped
from wednesday uh by the news from the
russian energy firm gasprom that both
poland and bulgaria will stop receiving
their gas uh from tomorrow presumably
it's this battle over payment in rubles
um but it feels like the first salvo in
what was one of russia's biggest
armaments which is its delivery of oil
and gas to europe sonia
yes i think that's right it's another
front in this um terrible war isn't it
and um you know obviously we you know
we're seeing the awful tragedy that's
taking place in ukraine the war crimes
that are being committed by putin's um
troops under his command
particularly in the east of ukraine at
the moment
but putin is also looking to use what
other levers that he has with the rest
of europe and i think you know cutting
off the power uh to to bulgaria is is
very much part of you know part of that
that set of levers to sort of say to
europe
if you continue to support ukraine if
you continue to arm ukraine uh there
will be consequences for you um so i
think this is this is just
it's just another example of the extent
to which um this war
and these actions by putin have really
really remarkably changed i think that
the geopolitics
of europe and indeed the world um very
dramatically over um over the last kind
of few weeks and that's a really
interesting graph there you know
bulgaria gets 77 of its um gas from
bulgaria obviously germany is very high
up on that chart as well as we know and
germany has come under significant
criticism in in recent days for not
doing more to um sort of wean itself off
uh russian gas gas to sort of to pull
the plug on it go to cold turkey and
russian gas as it were um you know we've
seen german politicians the bundesbank
say well
if if we were to do this um it would it
could harm you know you know the
consequences for germany would be pretty
terrible but actually i think you know
you've got you've got to say well
you know look at what's at snake here um
in ukraine so i think it's right that
germany's come under significant
criticism for not doing more to sort of
pull the plug on its russian gas yes uh
poland suggesting that uh you know guest
customers uh would not have their
supplies cut that its underground gas
store is 80 full and they're heading
into summer they've also
got alternative supply sources as well
including liquefied natural gas bulgaria
saying similar to be fair so we'll see
how that goes but it's clearly very
significant and that takes us to the
daily telegraph um christopher which is
liz truss uh talking um in what's billed
as a a major foreign policy speech about
the long haul we should anticipate for
ukraine and the telegraph going on the
impact on on all of this on defense
spending this suggestion that nato's two
percent of gdp um should be a minimum
really for what is required these days
well the big issue i think in spending
terms uh looking into this autumn is
going to be defense spending a lot of
touring p's i speak to have been tipped
off there's likely to be some movement
on the defense budget um when i last
looked of course liz trust was a foreign
secretary not actually the defense
secretary but she is of course one of
the two or three leading contenders to
replace boris johnson along with
ben wallace who is defense secretary so
i wonder whether ben wallace well he
probably would welcome the support from
the foreign secretary about increased
defense spending it makes me chuckle
inwardly i've been covered politics for
so long now i've gone gray that i can
just see how uh how these uh ministers
can work and how i'm getting involved in
the defense spending situation is is a
is a good um way to to to to show her
true blue not there and any doubt her
true blue torica credentials but this is
going to be one of the bd
the big debates of this autumn how much
more to spend on defence in the wake of
the the war in ukraine yeah that's
interesting and um the paper also
quoting uh jeremy hunt former foreign
secretary obviously also expected
possibly to run again uh to be a toy
leader should there be a vacancy who
knows um calling for uh defence spending
of close to four percent of gdp so as
you say it's it's part of the the battle
lines on that not yet a contest contest
uh anyway lots more still to come
including this tour on the front page of
the guardian dj westwood accused of
sexual misconduct by multiple women
their headlines
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now sonia soder chief
leader writer at the observer and
christopher hope associate editor for
politics at the daily telegraph welcome
back to both of you um sonny let's go to
the guardian shall we um its lead
stories about dj westwood accused of
sexual misconduct by multiple women
they're exclusive in this joint
investigation by the guardian and the
bbc the story under that though is about
the health agency set up to
to tackle coronavirus
is in turmoil they say staff carts of up
to 40 looming and plans to suspend
routine covert testing in hospitals and
care homes to save money
yes that's right so these are really big
cuts coming up quite soon on the cards
as you said staff cuts of up to 40
and i do think there are some quite
serious questions here now obviously
we're moving we've moved out of you know
really critical phase of the pandemic
and everyone hopes that there isn't a
new variant sort of lurking around the
corner that's going to
jeopardize the sort of a wall of
immunity that we've already built in
this country through vaccinations and
people get people getting infected
already um so you know it's it's it's
understandable that we're in a new phase
but i think there are really serious
questions because first of all you know
i i don't think we're at the stage where
we can where we can really significantly
cut back on testing yet and secondly one
of the things that really caught us with
covid was that we were not properly
prepared for a global pandemic and you
know lots of stuff has come out about
how um you know there were there were
these planning exercises you know five
years ago in the department of health
that showed britain's lack of
preparedness um and that this was not
acted on um so i would hope actually
that we'd from the lessons that we'd
learned from covid we would be
repurposing um this agency as the the
risks of covert sort of lesson over time
towards thinking about how we need to be
prepared for the next big pandemic
so i think it is a bit of a worrying
story from that perspective a couple of
um transport stories in fact on the
front of the financial times one is
about a creaking bus network
certainly in rural areas and the
importance of that for levelling up and
the other one is tesla so you've got
we've got minute 15 to do both of them
christopher take it away
well i'll go i'll go into fourth gear
for you and briefly on buses i think
it's fascinating and good for the ft
for bus service on page one they're a
big champion of leveling up um i think
this is a key part of it the the issue
of transport services around rural parts
of the country that they're saying here
that there's an uphill struggle to
reverse 40 years of neglect in bus
services i'm looking around elsewhere
the bbc reporting recently that 31 areas
were giving a billion pounds for new bus
services but campaigners said that was
woefully short of what's needed um i
think the government gets this but it's
very slow to bring back more services
investing more money they're trying to
bring back train services reversing the
beaching um the cuts back in the 60s but
i do think that bus services are
absolutely key for for dealing with
leveling up they are a nightmare if you
rely on buses um in rural parts of this
country and they must be improved and
good for the fda for covering it
covering it yes and i'll do tesla very
quickly apologies sonia um tesla dented
as investors count on
elon musk's
share sale of his tesla shares to pay
for twitter uh tesla's market value
falling by more than 100 billion today
as investors prepared for that sell-off
i'll let you do that next time
sonia soda and christopher lovely to see
both thank you very much indeed thank
you